can you define a high value woman to me
or to you
um I thought you woman is someone who
first of all has a lot of respect for
herself you know
um has a lot of like Pride you know
works hard men want prideful hard
workers
well I I feel like no because men
obviously just want someone who's
beautiful and is just gonna be
submissive and say yes and well that's
at least what we're being told but I
feel like I think that's not true
[Music]
no men don't like submissive women no I
don't think so no because I feel like
it's not about being submissive you just
have to be kind and you have to be
loving and you have to respect your man
a lot of women don't actually respect
their men